welcome back to las vegas now taco
friday it's from it's for tacotarian
though let me explain thanks to cisco
we've got the music playing the sponsors
of this segment we're hanging out with
local plant-based mexican eatery
tacotarian and let's welcome regina and
dan simmons the owners of this special
place i hear you guys are making vegan
tacos dreams come true is that is that
true that's a go we are yes you're
making vegan taco dreams come true i
love that so what's the concept what's
the tacotarian lifestyle
so tacotarian is a fully plant-based
mexican restaurant
and we um we incorporated all the
traditional flavors and styles of
mexican food but we do it with
completely 100 plant-based ingredients
wow now what does that mean for someone
out there who's like well i don't really
know what plant-based food is what is
that
well all our ingredients were we do
everything fresh we do partner with
cisco and they help us find a lot of um
plant-based uh ingredients okay good uh
the key right here as dan said is to
keep the essence of the mexican food and
those flavors and those salsa because i
smell it so that the essence is on point
so everything is traditional mexican
food but just happens to be vegan okay
okay so instead of like chicken tacos
what is it we use soy for chicken but
again we have like 15 different tacos
okay so we have a little bit for
everyone so you will find like your
traditional carne asada that is made
with mushrooms or maybe a baja taco
which is a beer butter avocado okay
chorizo
so we we really try to do veggies maybe
some soy maybe some uh seitan a little
bit of everything because some people
might not like soy some people might not
like uh gluten right so we try to
accommodate everyone but keeping that
essence of mexican food and those
flavors and fresh ingredients i love it
so what's your most popular taco because
that's the one i want to try right now
so
right now for this season we started
doing our birya tacos
which is a corn tortilla with melted uh
mozzarella cheese
yes and it comes with a little brother
you just dip in it and then it could be
a little messy just to do that okay and
then
what's mexican food if it's not messy
right
so you dip it on the breath and you just
eat it and it's way delicious hold on
you know i just i dipped it but i didn't
even ask is it spicy no it's not spicy
that's another one you gotta ask first
because you know i'm kind of a wimp
that's something that we wanted to do
with our food too all the spices are on
the side
wow that is amazing so what am i eating
right now so that it's a blend of
jackfruit
and beyonce tacos yeah so we and again
it's the seasoning it's all the love
that you put on those tacos it's amazing
tastes good wow okay so we have to wrap
soon so tell us you know what the
atmosphere like and how how can people
visit you yeah the atmosphere at
tacquitarian it's a very light fun
atmosphere you know you come in it's
quick service
we have all this beautiful food we have
these nice refreshing margaritas to wash
it down
and we currently have three locations in
the valley we have our original in the
southwest we have a location downtown in
the arts district and we have a third
out in henderson and you can also get
our food delivered to you uh exclusively
through the get loco app oh okay get
loco it is friday so that's all you look
these are so good thank you so much for
what you're bringing to the community
thank you to cisco for sponsoring this
segment tacoterian like you said three
locations downtown las vegas southwest
las vegas and henderson for more
information just head to
tacoterianlv.com good luck o.j